[Musik]
am 16 mai 1980 wird im wald von würenlos
die zwölfjährige rutscht ein mann
ermordet
viele jahre später fasst man ihren
mörder
doch heute ist klar die tat hat sich
ganz anders zugetragen als bisher
angenommen
[Musik]
als rutscht ein mann auf dem friedhof
der gemeinde würenlos beerdigt wurde war
sie zwölf jahre alt
roth spielte gerne flöte sie war ein
selbstbewusstes mädchen und aufgeweckt
für ihre familie die eltern und die zwei
schwestern war sie immer das rothley sie
ist es heute noch
rutz eltern lebe nun seit 26 jahren mit
dem verlust ihrer tochter
lange glaubten sie zu wissen was damals
geschah doch die bittere wahrheit ist
dass sie heute keinen schritt weiter
sind als damals
passiert wie heizung sowie dass ich
wahnsinnig malträtiert wurde was was ist
gegangen und das
bringen
als sich roth an jenem tag auf den
heimweg macht weiß noch niemand dass sie
ihren mörder begegnen wird
es ist ein ganz normaler freitag ein tag
wie jeder andere im leben von kindern im
leben von familien
mittag
mit berlin
um mit dem rookie acht gegen acht uhr
schule das ist ja noch da für mich nicht
sie ging es um gepostet sättigende und
seine erklärten sandalen über
und profitiert hier
mit dem velo und sowieso weg und traurig
nur mit sabine nach vigo posten und da
merkt man noch der sachsen abgeholt
und sollte zu diesem zeitpunkt längst zu
hause sein doch sie ist es nicht
die eltern machen sich getrennt auf die
suche nach gut das mädchen muss irgendwo
stecken es ist doch erst eine
dreiviertelstunde allein unterwegs
für frau abgeholt und sich sein jetzt
euro übernommen das sehen wir als
sechster von lahti haben
wieder zurückfahren und die musik und
text editor mit eingriff der welt ruft
rund und
vertreter
der fachakademie
unterwegs sind erklärt und ist ja an der
richtig weg
und wenn keine panik über nicht ob ich
ein christ was passiert ich aber
ganz komisches bekennt der trampelpfad
links ist an bord voller bis
und mit
direkten
sprung angriff noch ein rookie also
griff
und der mulden und hannes velux i think
tanks und denn es steht also ein alter
teppich qualitaet klagen der handel
blieb
lange
und so oft es ist nach springe und der
handelsroute freiheit oder sich auch
knebelt und und stranguliert sie und und
zerreißt und maxi hat sich
als das früher misshandelt und das ist
bild das sehr gut natürlich direkt
in verzweifelter hektik versuchen die
eltern ihr kind wiederzubeleben
vergeblich
der mörder seiner tochter war eben noch
hier im blickfeld des fahrers
am tatort findet die polizei wenig
spuren nur ein schamhaar und eine
bisswunde aufrufs brust
der mord an rothstein man im jahr 1980
ist der anfang einer schrecklichen reihe
von verbrechen an kindern
[Musik]
1982 rebecca biere aus dem kanton luzern
wird getötet
im selben jahr wird stefan brütsch im
kanton schaffhausen ermordet
1983 loredana mancini aus dem aargau
wird tot aufgefunden
ein halbes jahr später wird benjamin
engeli im kanton zürich tot aufgefunden
1984 peter roth aus dem kanton st gallen
ist bis heute verschwunden
1985 daniel sutter wird im aargau tot
aufgefunden im selben jahr sarah person
aus dem wallis bis heute unauffindbar
1986 edith dritten pass aus dem thurgau
verschwunden
1987 christian widmer wird im kanton
aargau tot aufgefunden
1989 fabian im hof wird im kanton
solothurn ermordet
die federführende aargauer
kriminalpolizei stand unter druck und
wandte sich mehrmals an die
öffentlichkeit auf ein und dieselbe
person als täter abzielen daniel suter
hat mit seinen eltern aus dorffest in
rümlang im kanton zürich besucht dort
ist das kind genau in diesen minuten
einem angriff ausgesetzt dem es nicht
gewachsen ist und der tragischerweise
von den augenzeugen völlig
missverstanden wird
dass ich jetzt zwei
weitere später wurde dann in super dann
rund 30 kilometer von rümlang entfernt
in einem maisfeld bei riniken gefunden
erdrosselt mit einer goldfarbenen
vorhang auf
schon wenige tage danach tauchte dann in
einer zeitung die bange frage auf wer
ist wohl das nächste opfer zunächst
schien es als sei diese frage
unangebracht dann aber zwei jahre später
zeigte sich dass sie doch berechtigt war
wieder ein festplatz wieder ein samstag
in der gemeinde windisch nur wenige
kilometer vom leichenfund auf den
wenigen entfernt feiert am 17 oktober
1987 eine jungschar ihr 50 jähriges
bestehen
während in der turnhalle von windisch
das jubiläumsfest auf vollen touren
läuft kommt es auf der landstraße
zwischen rufe nach und risiken zu einer
beobachtung die sicher bedeutsam ist ein
mofafahrer der problem jeder neue fall
wollte die eltern von ruth wieder
[Musik]
aufmachen
mit passiert
[Musik]
dass die hintere so lange trainer
aufgereiht werden das ist ganz sich mit
der polizei als last sondern der täter
hätte einfach lange zeit nicht
entscheidend fall gemacht
während die polizei auf den
entscheidenden fehler des mörders wartet
steigt die zahl der toten oder
verschwundenen kinder ende der 80er
jahre auf 11
auch im fall von rot steinmann kommen
die ermittlungen nicht voran
[Musik]
ganz am anfang ist schon mal
hand zum als welt braucht und fragte
hand und fingern abzählen können dass
ein mini kennen und ich noch nicht
gefunden etwas rücklage nicht berichtet
sie haben nicht das vorgesehene
quadratzentimeter absicht hat karriere
als juristin europa 34 tage handeln ist
er braucht was passiert ist wenn sie
nicht und ich selber zieht ist am summer
richter herr schwenn zitiert und herr
boris sind einmal ob und wann der mit
einem 80 und politisch
nichts
die polizei ließ die familie im stich
auch
psychologische betreuung gab es nicht
dafür kümmerten sich andere um sich
nachbarn freunde standen bei
doch dass man sie in ihrem leid auch
belästigte darauf waren die steine nicht
vorbereitet
telefon kaum noch und noch anonym von
morgens bis nachts um zwölf immer wieder
heimlich mit musik endete es ist schon
schlimm einer parade mal einfach
aufhören zu stecken ich weiß nicht was
dank
im sommer 1980 nach wochenlangem
telefonterror erhält felix steinmann
einen hinweis
dieses foto
schulz immer braucht zurückkam habe sich
die frauen mit abbruch zeit ist ein taxi
das könnte sie erleben dass so eine
bemerkung und ich hatte nicht mal zurück
fragt wo sind sie und zu wieder völlig
fit aber wieder weg sie und dreimaligen
auch die polizei erhielt dieses foto
damals sie will das heute nicht mehr
kommentieren inzwischen ist klar die
missachtung dieses fotos war ein fehler
[Musik]
neun jahre vergehen
dann die wende
1989 meldet sich werner ferrari bei der
polizei und wird verhaftet der
kindermörder scheint gefasst denn
ferrari ist der polizei bekannt
ferrari ist einschlägig vorbestraft
anfang der siebziger jahre wurde er
wegen der ermordung eines buben zu zwölf
jahren zuchthaus verurteilt
im bezirksgefängnis baden wartet ferrari
nun auf den prozess
in gezielten befragungen kommt das
schreckliche ans licht werner ferrari
gesteht vier morde an kindern an fabien
imhof christian widmer daniel sutter und
benjamin engel
[Musik]
den mord an ruth steinmann streitet er
von anfang an ab
[Musik]
wenn ferrari der motor um steinmann
bestritten dass er dies insofern deshalb
schon stutzig gemacht will mit einem
fall parallele vorhandenes ich sie zu
einer feier zur zeit
schon 1992 fand aus winzenried deutliche
worte zu werner ferrari in der
fachzeitschrift kriminalistik war für
winzenried klar dass ferrari viele
kinder getötet hat auch ruth steinmann
journalist peter holenstein hat damals
diesen artikel gelesen und war irritiert
sicher ganz klar die verursacher nicht
eilig sie
wurde tv auftritt wurde sind die drucke
entstand es gibt gar keine andere täter
muss krise ich hatte sehr unüblich kunde
dass ein kripo-chef
formen gerichtsurteil
eigentlich so eine vorverurteilung
verfasst
und
dann hat mich der aufgabe interessieren
heute morgen kurz vor halb neun wenn er
ferrari nach fünf jahren
untersuchungshaft auf dem weg in den
gerichtssaal der 81 jährige zürcher
anwalt karl scherer er verteidigt den
angeklagten der schon einmal wegen
kindstötung im gefängnis saß im
wettringer rathaus wo das verfahren aus
platzgründen stattfindet begann dann
auch alles wie erwartet der
pflichtverteidiger verlages hielt sich
zurück ferrari selber gab häufig
ausweichende antworten gab sich aber
erstaunlich gesprächig als dann aber
gerichtspräsident geht um 11 auf die zur
debatte stehenden tötungsdelikte zu
sprechen kam änderte sich das bild
ferrari widerrief seine geständnisse und
behauptete er habe diese ausschließlich
aufgrund von informationen gemacht der
von untersuchungsbeamten oder aus den
medien habe
ich bin überrascht sie das während
ferrari von amtes wegen ein 82-jähriger
scheidet als pflichtverteidiger bereit
sei nicht so unüblich kunde
und wie dann hat der prozess zeigt hat
sich alles in rasender geschwindigkeit
abgang bis auf die bis auf dem moment wo
dafür dass die geständnisse drucker hat
und grund warum die zurückzog heizstäbe
willen von hüfte vor unserer komisch dvv
der hohnsteiner wurde verfangen haben
abgestritten hat und nachdem er die
gestalten ist sogar der dhb
hat das mandat nichts ich begreife den
verteidiger dass er in dieser situation
dass man dort nicht mehr weiterführen
kann er war immer darum bemüht dass der
angeklagte verrate nur für die vier von
ihm zugestanden und delikte angeklagt
wird und der fünfte fall den ich noch
angeklagt habe fallen gelassen würde der
prozess gegen werner ferrari scheitert
schon am ersten tag am fall ruth steiner
und sich dann so weit der prozess wo
natürlich dann zwangsläufig den reinen
indizienprozess sich außer man hat müsse
ein ferrari teams bewiesen
[Musik]
das gericht befragte die polizisten
denen ferrari die vier morde einst
gestanden hatte
doch derjenige der den mutmaßlichen
mörder seiner tochter gesehen hat ging
vergessen
mit dem kolleg von mir krieg vor dem
kgb spion der monster wird
der ja wenn da sowohl
sprich jetzt der selber züge und das
nichts entstellen schulforum ex oder
klassisches hollandrad
an jugendämter ferrari
und das genau wie komisch berührt
dass man doch einfach so
ferraris neuer anwalt erkundigt sich
nach dem schamhaar welches vor 15 jahren
aufwuchs leiche gefunden wurde
das haar sei nach amerika geschickt
worden für eine dna analyse das gericht
muss aber zugeben dass die analyse im
ganzen ermittlungsverfahren nicht
gemacht wurde
grossandrang von den gerichtssaal man
verweist über das urteil
keine zweifel deinen gerichtssaal das
urteil ganz klar lebenslänglich für mord
in fünf fällen dazu eine psychotherapie
gerichtspräsident neff war dennoch um
etwas verständnis für ferrari für einen
verstopften mit einem denkbar
schwierigen leben einer der sehnsucht
hatte nach liebe und geborgenheit und
dann so viel leid brachte über diese
kinder ihre eltern ihre angehörige heute
am dritten tag wurde ferrari erstmals
heftig als der gerichtspräsident
schilderte wie ferrari die opfer
misshandelt hatte explodierte er
schweinerei was sie mit mir macht rief
er später gelogen ihr werdet büßen
1995 wird werner ferrari schuldig
gesprochen des fünffachen mordes
auch dem an roth steigern
in der strafanstalt lenzburg sitzt er
seine strafe ab zuchthaus lebenslang
doch sitzt mit ihm auch der wahre mörder
von ruth steinmann hinter gitter
[Musik]
diese frage beschäftigt bis heute auch
den strafrechtsprofessor daniel jositsch
das studieren und hinterfragen von
gerichtsurteilen ist für ihn berufliche
alltag
sich natürlich im büro saß sie
in rom und buch veröffentlich kite
stattgefunden hat man hat die mordrate
wählen auf kleine werner rage ist
verurteilt wurde mit 0 4 fall sondern
auch wie vorfall sowie dem fall steigern
und prag wo man sich stellen ob das
wirklich prächtig ist das wirklich so
erzähle stattfinden es gilt der
grundsatz im zweifel für den angeklagten
und der gilt auch in vier fällen
verurteilt wird für das man muss also
immer mehr fünfter fall können die und
stichfest nahe wiese
schuldig ist weil mir das nicht kann
muss meinem freisprach jetzt ist sie
relativ schwach sie ist keine aktive sky
um von dem her muss mindestens frage
stelle ob die verurteilung kraftrad xe
ist oder nicht
er will es nun genau wissen journalist
peter holenstein reist von seinem
wohnort in italien wiederholt in die
schweiz
er verbringt stunden mit werner ferrari
und mit familie steim an seiner
recherchen sind der auslöser für die
justiz tragödie um ruth steiner
sie beginnt mit dem schamhaar welches
zur dna-analyse nach amerika geschickt
wurde
noch nicht mitgemacht haben hätte ich
natürlich gar nicht gleich etwas das
auch über habe nirgendwo mensch und habe
mich einfach mal erkundigen im
rechtsmedizinischen institut in zürich
bin professor bob
einflüsse wo das haar sekunde mit einem
freundlich zurück geschrieben ja das
gebe ihm dass er gewinnen aber
das ist
amerika nicht untersucht wieder ein
professor behr hat das know how
und dann habe ich mich erkundigt ist es
möglich dass ich das auf
privatinitiative sondern denen auch in
die macher hat einen lang lang müssen
darum kämpfen bis dann letztlich die
justizdirektion im kanton aargau gesagt
okay gut sich etwas machen ob es
immerhin zeitlich zahlen
und
dann hat man das gemacht den
rechtsmedizinischen institut in lausanne
haben die dna gemacht
und hat sich rausgestellt das haar ist
nicht von ferrari
die nachricht schlägt ein
auch bei den eltern von ruth
[Musik]
tennisspieler ist natürlich im prinzip
vor gericht wiederholen wenn es nix ich
den handel oder
gmx sie
in oberland
hinweise gab es schon früh auf ihn
bereits 1982 ging sein schwager zur
polizei er ist überzeugt dass er mit dem
mord an rothstein man etwas zu tun hat
die annahme dass werner ferrari rutscht
ein mann ermordet hat kommt immer mehr
ins wanken das urteil aus dem jahre 95
kann nicht mehr bestehen im jahr 2003
wird es im fall roth steinmann
aufgehoben der mord an ruth kommt
voraussichtlich noch dieses jahr erneut
vor gericht
mansiz und was krieg feststelltaste
werner frage er dort nicht verwirkt hat
wenn er dazu verurteilt worden ist dann
ist das ein justizirrtum ein
justizirrtum wo wir jetzt mal skurril
ehre das mag auf den ersten blick
vielleicht zynisch wirken man setze die
sie dass der berner vereine vier anderen
fall verurteilt wird man hat sich ab
frage stelle ich das wirklich
wichtig dass in
vilich 20 sie nur für je 4 vl und areva
verurteilt wird auch das ist ganz
wichtig es geht um das militär wo man
vorwirft dass er gegen gesetze verstoßen
hat dass er in kraft sich mit dem brand
das wir vor der gesellschaftliche sieht
daher vom strafrecht aus ihm zeigen mir
dünnt ich trotzdem frei und gerecht
behandeln mit intimität so folger wenig
ihr vorwerfen dass du nicht vorgegangen
ist also mir zeige dir was richtig ist
es gibt auch das muss man auch sagen der
anspruch von opfern vor allem von der
opferfamilie nicht einfach
irgendeine sondern was möglich sei
die hinweise gegen er sind erdrückend
doch dieser kann nicht mehr befragt
werden er hat 1983 selbstmord begangen
seine leiche wird 2004 exhumiert
die offenen fragen sollen nun endlich
geklärt werden
[Musik]
der wissenschaftliche dienst der zürcher
stadtpolizei analysiert die gebisse von
werner ferrari und des exponierten dr
die ausgangslage ist günstig die beiden
haben völlig unterschiedliche auffällige
zahnstellung
also vor allem steigende ruf dass
exhumierten haben rasieren unregelmäßige
zahnstellung im untergriffe daher sogar
ein zahn der staat wirklichkeit nimmt
grad eigentlich verehrt und bin während
ferrari darf alt sofort auf dass er um
zehn und die hat und nicht hier
die vermessung mit dem 3d sträflich
scanner ist hoch präzise
[Musik]
dieses aufwendige verfahren mitgemacht
weil der mörder von rothstein mann das
mädchen gebissen hat die gebisse von
werner ferrari und des exponierten
werden deshalb mit der wunde verglichen
[Musik]
fixierte verschiedene dispositionen dass
das teil sieht das für die nutzung wie
ich selber das ist jenes teils der natur
eines grashalm oder so
begründet hieß es 3 d modell mehr hits
maßstäblich wie die wunden ihnen drucke
und jetzt immer sehr
deutlich wie immer zum beispiel das sei
jetzt klar der wunde zu
praktischen ins kart tretet sei wo man
sie die wunde stecke während
miteinanders beurteilt und sind zum
schluss hoch dass man der werner ferrari
könnte schade dass er das nicht
appliziert der eitle und das muss in
engste betrachten sie das der exhumiert
die
babys verursacht hat das eindeutige
resultat liegt seit letztem herbst vor
hat die polizei 26 jahre auf den
falschen täter gesetzt tatsache ist dass
ferrari
verurteilt roten ecke vielfach renz
tätig tatsache ist dass der wellen
ferrari vier vorteile fällt allerdings
vor gericht mit der
tatsache dass der wähler ferrari
die verurteilung wegen vielfachen
kindsmord cas rechtsmittel ergriffen und
das alles ich fries doch
grund nur dass mir bisher polizeilich
nicht überzeugt sie hat
der welt ein ferrari-triumph steinmann
jedoch und macht unabhängig von dem
gutachten erstellt worden ist es hat
andere indizien
prozess in baden im wald steinmann wo
der wähler ferrari belastet um die in
diez die sie auch mit einem gutachter es
nicht aus der welt schafft
tatsache ist das gebiss gutachten
entlastet werner ferrari
und belastet
es beweist dass er rutscht ein mann
etwas angetan hat und
wie sich herausstellt war der täter
nicht alleine schon vor jahren hat er
sich eine augenzeugen gemeldet
sie freut sich bei der opferhilfe und
hatte seine sektor 12 er ist mit steyr
managern quasi flug gespielt für
täterschaft
und wenn es zutrifft dass die seite dann
ist sie selber so fuchs ist haben als
12x sie ist nach ihrer eigenen aussage
schwer missbraucht wurden seit ihrem
achten lebensjahr
und
wir sie auf die täterschaft kurs wo sie
aufgehört das tut sich erst jetzt
langsam aussteller
weiß dass das gebiss gutachten vorliegt
von dem tatverdächtigen
im einverständnis mit der zeugin
informiert peter holenstein den aargauer
kripochef urs
winzenried ist einverstanden dass die
frau von einem fachmann vom psychiater
mario enzensberger befragt wird
nachrichten von der kripo
dass sie leider nicht dafür den mitteln
aus der regensburger nötig mit einer
frau reden will das staatsoberhaupt
verfügte
derselbe staatsanwalt der werner ferrari
wegen fünffacher mord bauch de man
rutscht ein mann hinter gitter brachte
ist heute noch in den fall involviert
ein interview mit ihr ab
seinen ermittlungs stopp begründete er
vor zwei jahren
[Musik]
das politisch für die hat das ist ein
inzest begangen wurden und fertigt frist
für seitige delikte maxim und 20 jahren
für die neue deutsche schafft zu oft hat
daher zusätzliche chrom tag der darf man
nun wieder forscher
ist tot und gegen tote wird nicht
ermittelt sagt der staatsanwalt er
gegen tote wird nicht ermittelt ist
meines erachtens der falsche satz
ermittelt wird nicht gegenüber sondern
der möglichkeit zum ziel hauptkläger was
passiert ist nachher kam sich frage
untersucht wird nach lage operiert aber
csu schon mal gefragt was ist passiert
und bevor man nicht weiß was passiert
ist weiß man dagegen die pannen und die
leitern oder nicht es gibt neue
besonders es muss ja nicht nur immer
jeden einzeln für sich konnte sondern es
können johanniter vorhanden sie es
können hilfen oder rauschgift fanden sie
und ihren juni wieder das neue habe
[Musik]
die augenzeugin hatte ausgesagt der
staatsanwalt blockte ab als sie später
doch noch befragt werden sollte war es
zu spät sie entschuldigt sich mit einem
psychiatrischen gutachten die gefahr
einer retraumatisierung sei zu groß nur
man natürlich sehr retro optimiert habe
nur personen werden tatsächlich so
erlebt hat
also ich muss sagen traue ich selber bin
überzeugt dass die züge schlüsselperson
ist
für kleidung für die wirklichkeit vor
dem fall
ich wollte mich zeigen dass alles was
sie mir zeit hat und worauf der umbau
ist
dass das alles zusammen stehen sich seit
damals zu häufig sie aber es geht in den
usa ein schlüsselpunkt wo sie nötig an
erfunden aber beim besten willen nicht
gefunden und wohl nur über ein widget
atx ist dass ich hier tätig gestanden
das ist nicht einmal ein prozess zur
sprache
das ist ein sohnes markantes detail und
so ein wichtiges detail und das hat sich
gelöst und das detail ist der auslösung
sie wie sie seit das ihres drei mal
wieder aufgebrochen ist noch so viel
mehr darum bin ich überzeugt das ist ein
bistro und so ist jetzt nach neuestem
stand ausgesät hat sich jetzt das noch
verdichtet
will es spricht sehr vieles dafür
dass die zügel der verstorbene
dr tatsächlich konnten
[Musik]
peter holenstein befasst sich nun seit
über 30 jahren mit kriminalfällen
[Musik]
der fall roth steinmann ist jener der
ihn am meisten beschäftigt
viele stunden hat er mit familie stein
land verbracht aber auch mit anderen
eltern vergessen sie aber auch die
ältere muss sind bestätigt auch nicht
gefunden wurden ist da machen sich keine
vorstellung was die eltern mitmachen
jeden tag jeden tag
und dann gibt es die ältere woods war
gefunden wurden ist ob man weiß nicht
wer der täter ist
und ich fühle mich eigentlich sehr
verbunden und und das ist sicher teil wo
mich zu motiviert hat ahold nv bietet
bliebe wie gesagt vielleicht gibt es
einen zusammenhang zwischen einer frau
und
wir sehen das eigene filter wieder zu
machen
die aargauer justiz muss werner ferrari
demnächst erneut vor gericht laden
auch wenn er am ortrud steinwand
freigesprochen werden sollte an seiner
lebenslangen strafe wird das nichts
ändern
doch wenn ferrari im fall roth steinmann
freigesprochen wird wer dann hat das
mädchen getötet
der aargauer staatsanwalt sagt der fall
sei verjährt
heißt das die wahrheit kommt nie ans
licht
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass das der fall lose
steine und verjährt ist respektive ich
glaube dass man da sich kaum beurteilen
wenn man wirklich weiß was passiert ist
nach dem damals geltenden recht verjährt
ein mord nach 20 jahren das heißt im
jahr 2000 ist der fall steigern
theoretisch fährt jetzt ist es so dass
damals für ihr können unterbrochen
werden und dann läuft sie mit maximal
während reese kdh bis zum jahr 2010 es
ist sogar möglich dass verjährt und da
könnte sogar noch übers jahr 2010 auf
erfolg oder nicht das weiß man erst wenn
man es mit einer konkreten person store
hat wohl steinbrocken und mit außen
beurteilen
solange das nicht der fall ist kann man
nur sagen es ist jahr 2002 muss mit
theoretischem alter von booz co das für
mich nun auf
[Musik]
die eltern sehen dem prozess mit bangen
gefühlen entgegen
[Musik]
wenn der nächste prozess der ferrari
kein fleisch spricht also nicht nur zur
teilung schreibt sondern frei spricht
und noch da die staatsanwalt als wir
ziehen die strategie sie
seid ja und wahrscheinlich verjährt
da finde ich das als katastrophal
also wenn das bild sieht ruft wolle dort
findet dann muss doch dass der anwalt
vom start sie
[Musik]
roth wurde den eltern genommen
ob verjährt oder nicht wer ihre tochter
wirklich getötet hat nur noch das wollen
sie endlich wissen
[Musik]